in 1992 nickelodeon debuted the tv show
guts
it was just like american gladiator only
the contestants were all kids the rocks
have doubled the smoke is smoking and
while the show was epic in every way the
theme song is one of those pieces where
you start singing it and somebody next
to you joins in
so we found the guy who wrote it my name
is rick murkowski and i am the composer
of the
nickelodeon theme song
guts
i got the call to do this
piece hip hop was just coming to age
immediately it came to mind
do you have it guts they liked it and
they said you think you could put a
little wrap to it
i said sure
i'm a polish guy from west virginia i
can rap yeah
it takes a certain kind of something to
keep the heart popping something
everybody needs to achieve to succeed
you'll need a lot
of work
they were big on the sound effects stuff
in that too you can hear me in your
i sampled my myself so rick he didn't
just write the theme song for guts he
was kind of the 90s jingle guy for
nickelodeon gotcha was my first yeah
first show for nickelodeon i did some
music for the big help
did all the music for kids choice awards
figure it out
the remake of family double dare
i did stuff for nick at night also nick
at night
oh but here's a show i forgot to mention
i did the music for a show called action
league now action league now starring
the flesh
my bucket list i i
you know i'd love to be involved in
having a hit record you know
i'm still working on that but i guess
you know to a degree like the gut steam
it's my hit so i'm pretty happy about
that
you